2018 pour les collèges une rentrée
ambitieuse pour le département 500
millions d'euros sont sains seront
investis dans les dix prochaines années
au programme le développement du
numérique l'augmentation de
l'enseignement bilingue et surtout de
gros chantier de restructuration de
plusieurs établissements dont celui de
saint-amarin que vous voyez sur ces
images on écoute
brigitte klinkert la présidente du
conseil départemental du haut rhin
ce chantier sis au collège de
saint-amarin chantier sur trois ans de
10 5 millions d'euros est vraiment un
symbole nous avons il ya deux ans lui
sur pierre livre blanc des collèges et
nous avait répertorié tous les collèges
dans desquelles doivent se faire des
travaux et nous avons à présent dans
c'est un plan ambitieux de travaux de
150 millions d'euros dans les collèges
les prochaines années outre
l'enseignement dans les collèges le
conseil départemental investit aussi
dans l'engagement citoyen des jeunes
dans la culture et le sport
et là c'est notre nouveau défi elle
marque aussi